being a dad changed you as a person do
you believe I think it's just unlocking
the inner door key dead that I've always
been you have always been a dorky dad it
was just waiting yeah excuse of a job
now I have the kin they're like I get
all the puns now like it makes sense but
I don't know I'm almost 40 and I'm
getting tired of my personality I don't
don't get me wrong oh no I get it no I
there's just moments that I catch myself
and I'm just like who have I become now
that I'm almost 40 I'll give you an
example I was a tie in line at the
airport for airport security and there's
his mom and her son in front of me
must've been like eight years old like a
Yoda backpack Orange Crocs with the
holes in it like a real cute kid and
they were super close and to pass the
time as a long line to pass the time
they were playing a game that they made
up where they were naming liquids that
you're not allowed to bring on the plane
mm-hmm
boring but I had nothing else to do so
I'm listening and play and the kids like
Mountain Dew
I can't bring Mountain Dew on the plane
when the moms like milk yeah
you can't bring milk on the plane then
the kid gets a little cheeky kid goes
pee you can't bring pipian the plane
this is where 40 year old me decides to
chime in oh boy this is a real story
this happened on earth I know all your
all your stories are real but it's it
sounds unreal I don't know who I've
become that I'm like they want to hear
from a stranger traveling alone but I
lean my big bulbous head in between them
and I went excuse me you can bring pee
on a plane if it's in your bladder
[Laughter]
they froze yeah
took three unavailable steps away from
me
and I was just crying after them like
you can bring milk to your mom remembers
like what your retreat is what you have
tried that's the momentum mama that's
that's the feeling of 40 is like
everyone wants to hear what this was man
happy to say liquids in your body are
okay now I only have to list the did you
keep playing with them were they the
rest of the flame and you'd be surprised
where you can get tazed
[Laughter]